it's Tuesday and there's two of us I'm
Dan I'm Jess and this is gamespot news
why did i do shooty fingers I don't know
that was weird
[Music]
first up the original minions Rabbids
are teaming up with Mario for a Nintendo
switch game nope
what do you mean no I don't like him
don't like them why because they look
like Muppets and I'm scared of Muppets I
do not have time to unpack that the
first image of Ubisoft's rumored Mario /
Rabbids crossover for the switch
appeared on Twitter after allegedly
surfacing on discord use a fatal flaw we
did us all a solid by saving and
subsequently tweeting the image so we
can all speculate and just consume end
her irrational phobia of puppets the
image shows a rabid dressed as Princess
Peach and following the leak
comicbook.com reported that it verified
the image with anonymous sources and
published the full piece of art which
you've probably been staring at for 10
seconds now if Dan couldn't find any
other relevant Ferrell to edit over this
segment
Ubisoft hasn't officially announced
Mario and rabbits kingdom battle but it
sure looks like it's on the way back in
January journalists Laura Kate Dale
reported on rumors of the crossover
saying the game will be a turn-based
strategy RPG with local co-op support
and eight playable characters Mario
Luigi Yoshi peach and for Rabbids doing
what I can only assume is attempting to
assume their forms Capcom has revealed
that Dragon's Dogma dark arisen is
coming to ps4 and Xbox one this fall the
rerelease was announced by the game's
official Facebook page and on Twitter
where the tweet read reclaim your heart
in the epic action RPG Dragon's Dogma
darker ISM unfortunately Capcom haven't
suggested what changes are coming with
the release but a bump in graphical
quality seems like a safe bet dark
arisen originally came out for Xbox 360
and ps3 in 2013 as an expanded and
enhanced version of the core Dragon's
Dogma title it later arrived on PC with
increased fidelity and other steam
bonuses like achievements if you want to
know more you can subscribe to us so
that when we know you'll know it's the
anniversary of the launch of overwatch
and to celebrate Blizzard have launched
an anniversary event well done thank you
there's also a sale on the game
the event which adds a hundred new
cosmetic items through commemorative
loot boxes and three new arena maps is
now live on all platforms the new loot
boxes will let you limited time event
cosmetics such as skins emotes sprays
and more if you ask me those skins
expand on the Lord of overwatch like how
Lucy I didn't always have dreads and
diva was clearly in no doubt the three
new arena maps are based on I can world
Dorado and temple of Anubis and are
built for 3v3 elimination you'll be
fighting in necropolis where honor can
keep an eye on things the old fort
Castillo with its graffiti de lausanne
watchers hang out and the misty black
forest on the outskirts of Ike involved
if you haven't jumped into overwatch yet
- there is currently a sale on the game
of the year edition that will set you
back 40 bucks
while the standard edition has been
dropped to 30 bucks if you'd rather
spend no dollars you can also play the
game for free next weekend that is
everything we've got for you today do
let us know down in that comment box
what you thought of today's stories and
let us know what you thought of today's
show and we will see you again tomorrow
should I've blinked when I was looking
in the camera